yesterday on the bonus show I told you
that Donald Trump claims to be planning
another summit with North Korean leader
Kim jong-un supposedly this is going to
happen at the end of February and you
might remember that that first meeting
they had in Singapore was just an
absolute and total failure the media
coverage was sort of glowing at least
from some enclaves Trump certainly
claimed victory during the flight back
from Singapore but nothing has happened
we have no reason to think that North
Korean nuclear development has stopped
we still haven't heard a thing about
getting those remains of American
soldiers repatriated back to the United
States we now have a report that claims
that it's actually maybe even worse than
we thought in North Korea because
researchers have found a secret
ballistic missile base in North Korea
which the North Koreans haven't even
admitted exists as a missile base it's a
facility that we're aware of but we
didn't know until more recently that it
appears to be a missile base and the
report says that there may be as many as
20 of these previously undisclosed
mishel missile testing sites the one
that they named specifically is the sino
re missile Operating Base where
ballistic missiles are being developed
and these are the types of missiles that
could potentially be used to deliver a
nuclear warhead which of course North
Korea's also developing this is a report
from defense think-tank CSIS through a
project of theirs called beyond parallel
the White House was asked for comment as
of this morning they have not given a
comment it's important to understand
that if North Korea doesn't disclose
somewhere between 1 and 20 missile sites
those aren't missile sites that could be
on the negotiating table for Donald
Trump since they're not even disclosed
and acknowledged and to be clear the US
has known about a lot of these locations
as places where things have been going
on but the big news here is that it has
become a missile facility and something
that's neither here nor there in
evaluating the sort of logic behind
Donald Trump's summits with Kim jong-un
and the
number of facilities that they may have
for missile testing is the topic of
chemical warfare it's not mentioned much
within North Korea but it's a big big
threat there's a report from ten years
ago
that North Korea has a stockpile of
somewhere between 2,500 and 5,000 metric
tons of chemical weapons and this
includes some of the common ones mustard
gas sarin and some other less-common
nerve agents which of course could do
huge huge damage to neighboring
countries and for me the fear isn't so
much that North Korea is going to on a
whim
out of nowhere unilaterally attack the
United States or our allies or their
neighbors it's more that when you have
erratic people like Trump dealing with
them they may end up retaliating or
reacting in a disastrous way and
everything is just opposite with Trump
when it comes to this stuff he says on
the flight back from Singapore after the
first summit on Twitter North Korea is
no longer a threat
turns out they potentially have 20 more
missile sites than what we even knew
about they said last week Isis has been
defeated on the same day that they
attack and kill four people and within
five days another suicide attack just a
few days later I don't know Pat what
there is to gain from having Donald
Trump sit down with Kim jong-un again do
you think that there's even a chance
that a second summit could actually
accomplish anything no and I mean if
these conversations were being had in
good faith then you'd have to cancel the
meeting right why would you have a
second summit between Trump and Kim
jong-un if they're adding nuclear
missile facilities you would definitely
want to cancel the meeting but of course
the White House is staying silent on
this they want to have that second
summit because it's good PR for the
president and the media seems to fawn
over it the funniest thing for me still
is that Donald Trump genuinely thinks to
seems to think of it as an
accomplishment that Kim jong-un was
willing to meet with him like Trump
seems to be thinking about this like wow
I secured a meeting with Kim jong-un
which is extraordinarily difficult to do
and of course if
have any knowledge of the backstory in
the last 20 years or even more with
North Korean leaders you know that
they've always wanted to get a meeting
with an American president in order to
get those pictures and the propaganda
value and being able to say we're on the
same level as an American president and
it's been the American presidents who
have said well in order to really have
the conversation about meeting we're
going to have to get some agreement via
some preconditions need to be
established and there's going to have to
be some concessions made by the North
Korean leader before we even meet that
seems to not even enter into Trump's
mind he seems to think that it's it's an
incredible accomplishment just to have
been able to get a meeting with Kim
jong-un and I'm not sure if anybody in
the White House is explaining to him
that that's not the case of my question
to you do you support a second summit
between Donald Trump and Kim jong-un and
if you do please tell me why because at
this point I can't think of any good
reason for this to go forward make sure
you're following me on Instagram at
David Pakman and make sure you follow
the show on instagram at david pakman
show where I believe it's tomorrow if
Pat allows it that I will be answering
questions on our Instagram page from the
audience we'll see I'll talk about that
tomorrow if indeed it is happening if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out
the David Pakman show today is sponsored
by Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months
by using the link underneath this video
two months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video